Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday, July 7th and this is not some kinda fancy camera
trick, I am really that pale.
So Hank, I'm gonna do a Question Tuesday today.
But instead of answering a lot of questions quickly,
I'm going to answer a few questions lengthily.
But before I do that I have to change
shirts because right now I match the wall.
Movie Magic!
Was Brotherhood 2.0 initially your idea or was it Hank's?
Well the initial idea was mine but it
has to be said that I have a crazy idea
at least once every 45 minutes. And I
count on Hank to be like "That is a
terrible idea" and when I pitched him the
idea for Brotherhood 2.0 he was like
"That is not terrible", so we did it.
What did you do before you became an author?
For most of my postcollege life, I worked at this wonderful magazine called Booklist.
But I also worked as a hospital chaplin at a children`s hospital.
And I worked at like a Steak `n Shake
doing the graveyard shift which I do not recommend.
I mean honestly if anyone is thinking of dropping out of college,
get thee to Steak `n Shake.
What are the best books for aspiring writers to read as inspiration?
I'm going to have to say my books. In fact I'm
gonna have to say that the best way to
get inspired to write is to buy twenty
or thirty copies of each of my books.
I`m sorry. You know once you finish your book, they want you to transform from an
extraordinarily pale nerd who sits in a
basement and writes all day
to some kind of like selling machine.
So, I'm trying to practice a little bit.
But really all I wanna do is stay home, make videos, eat Peeps and
hang out with Willie.
What's the meanest thing you ever did to Hank?
Hmm,  I think I might've tried to kill him with a hammer once when we were little.
Wait or did he try to kill me?
I'm calling mom.
Hey, it's John. Quick question for you.
Ummm
Did I try to kill Hank with a hammer when I was little?
It was the other way around.
He tried to kill me!
Pwned! Uhm, did I ever try to kill Hank in any in any
way at all?
Yes
Oh, I did. Shocks.
What did I specifically do to try
to kill him though?
I tried to smother him. That's not, that's just hugging.
That's not killing. These are all very
bad behaviors like it's bad to
uh pour red cough syrup all over the
bed spread.
But it's nothing like Hank trying to
murder me with a hammer.
Well I'm sure I was being irritating but he tried to kill me
with a hammer.
I feel like I'm really getting the short end of the stick here like
you're like oh well he did try to
murder you with a hammer but there was
that one time that you spilled red cough syrup on the bed spread and then
gave him a, gave him a big hug
I'm sorry if I tried to smother Hank by
giving him a hug because I love him so
much and he tried to kill me with a hammer.
Okay so there you have it, according to my mom the meanest thing Hank ever did to
me was try to kill me with a hammer and the meanest thing I ever did to him was
spill some red cough syrup on his bed spread and then hug him too hard.
And yet somehow mom seems to be making the case that I was somehow
the inferior sibling.
How often do you get recognized?
Does it make you feel happy or slightly awkward?
I get recognized pretty often if I'm in
a big public space but it doesn't make
me either happy or slightly awkward. It's just kinda nice to meet a Nerdfighter.
Like the other day I was standing in
line for the Indiana Jones ride at
Disneyland and someone tapped me on the shoulder and said
"Are you from YouTube?" and then his little
brother who'd never heard of Nerdfighters
looked up at me and said
"Are you wearing a disguise?" and I was like, "Nope, these are real".
What advice do you have for writers who can't seem to finish their books?
Not much, I mean it took me four years to finish Looking for Alaska.
So I'm clearly not an expert in the field of finishing.
Just keep at it.
Can I have one of the advanced readers copies of Paper Towns?
Umm, no. Because I don't have any.
In fact, the people who already won advanced readers
copies of Paper Towns are still waiting for them.
A situation which I hope to rectify tomorrow.
However I do have three of these very
beautiful and very rare Paper Towns
discussion guides.
Which I flagrantly stole from my publisher and then like literally like put in my
shirt and walked out the convention
center.
So if anybody wants one of these which actually will be really helpful and
interesting when you read the book.
Leave me a question in comments that I can answer
when I do one of these next.
By the way, did you guys like the paperback cover of
An Abundance of Katherines?
Coming out on August 8 for a mere three dollars and ninety nine cents.